I'm
the one when we move,
we moved,
we went to Ireland because of the death
death of my,
my little sister.
And there were uh,
my brother frank,
myself and twin boys,
oliver and Eugene,
and when we got to Ireland,
uh,
we want to,
within two years the two boys,
you're Jaden Oliver died when they were
about four and four and a half of
various ailments at the time that nobody
cared too much about what was going on
with poor people.
There were no autopsies or anything.
He just died.
He just died and good riddance.
But,
uh,
but when we got a children's levels,
three and a half,
frank was born,
uh,
we were known as Yanks and uh,
you feel outside the tribe when you are
speaking differently,
acting differently,
behaving differently.
So as quickly as possible,
you made the attempt to be a get in with
the gang,
talk like them and be like them and
dressed like them.
So,
but no,
no matter what we did,
we were still yanks.
So then we grow up there and we come to
America,
uh,
back to America back here.
And they say,
Oh,
you're Irish over there were yanks over
here were Irish.
So my brother frank and myself decided a
long time ago that worked for your very
simply is we are New Yorkers.
This is our country,
this is my land,
this is the place for me where every
single dream I ever had came to fruition
and I love her dearly.
I love Yellow York
to be Irish in 2010,
2010.
There was a.
There is a pride in our
that that that's happened in our
intellectual accomplishments and our
literary accomplishments,
accomplishments in our technological
accomplishments,
but here to for a after,
oh,
800 years of occupation and the function
of the oppressor is to assure you that
you are nothing,
that you're nobody,
that you're less than deserving of
nothing.
That you are a piece of shit and I'm
don't aspire to anything,
and they infuse you with with shame,
which has to do with the past because
the all shamans based family in the
past.
It has to do with what you have done,
what you thought you will have done.
Ad Wants has sometimes seamus and juiced
by what has been done to you and by
allowing things to be done to you,
you are ashamed of not resisting.
So that's one part of a of oppression is
to make sure,
make sure you're a shameful,
shamed human being,
a then on the other,
and that takes care of the past and the
future has to do with fear.
Don't attempt to come up here.
Don't attempt to go forward.
You are,
you were nobody.
You are nobody and you'll always be
nothing.
So don't even think about coming here
because if you do something awful will
happen to you.
So we were,
we were caught between the two demons to
devil's shame and fear,
and we couldn't deal with the present,
which was that we are indeed as
accomplished in our own minds,
as spiritual,
as any other people,
as good as any other people.
But uh,
we could not look in the mirror.
I never said that.
That's what we are.
So to be Irish today is the abandonment
of that shame and the younger people are
moving it out and they're moving the
fear away.
They're not afraid,
they're adventurous,
they're going about the world as a care,
not carefree,
carefree,
I suppose.
But as with confidence and with the,
uh,
with the knowledge of the language,
with the education,
linguistically capable,
poetic and fun,
loving with a love of song and of life
itself.
So that for the younger people to be is,
um,
is,
is a great,
this wonderful thing that is happening.
The older ones of my generation are,
um,
in infused with.
They're still have the fear and the
various
ethnic groups have,
have diseases that are peculiar to their
group.
And for example,
Jewish people have a taste sacks and the
African Americans have sickle cell
anemia.
And the,
uh,
the Irish disease was respectability and
that infects them a lot.
And there was a,
what would somebody say was,
what would they say?
What would the English say if you wore
that?
Said that,
be that.
So consequently,
as the Irish poet a,
he said you eventually become the thing
you hate the most.
That's why so many of these Yahoos,
particularly the ones that run the
center St Patrick's Day parade are
conservatives.
And that conservatism is,
is not a political ideology.
It is a form severe form of brain damage
for which has hardly any cure.
I don't know what,
uh,
what we can do with them as a whole,
but they are gradually moving out.
The younger folks have taken over and
some day there may be some culture in
this St Patrick's Day,
but I prefer if it were an Irish parade
like Israel,
Israel has a as a,
a parade that's Israel not devoted to
Moses or Abraham or Moses and Abraham.
And so I'd like to see the day when this
was an Irish because you can't be grand
marshal of this charade if you're not a,
a Catholic.
And they say a practicing Catholic.
Now,
a lot of these guys are hypocrites when
they are about,
they're about as a practicing as,
as I am.
And I don't certainly am not.
I have the whole thing myself.
But they are the,
it's hypocritical anyway,
and I hope that one day it will be an
IRA would be nourished,
prayed,
then I would march future.
If you have,
if you have one foot in the future and
one foot in the past,
you're pissing on the present.
So I stay in the present.
So I don't know about the future.